How Do We Solve 4/5 +
9/5 We're Trying to Add to Rational Numbers
Here It's Definitely Not a Straight Forward As Adding
to Integers Remember One
Golden Rule When We Ever Compare Add and
Subclause Same as for Addition The first step is
to  Make the Denominator Same In this example we can see
the denominator is already the same.
In the second step we just did the numeration
over the denominator. The numeration is 4 and 9
and the denominator is 5. The sum will be there four equal
4+ 9 / 5  What is
13/5 Many students
tend to forget the third step which is simplifying the answer to
its standard
form Can this number be reduced further Now
13/5 is already in its standard form
and that makes it our final answer The second
example will give  You have a better idea we want to
add 5/8 and
7/1 the denominators are different in this case
so in the first step we have to get the
denominator same the common denominator will be the
least common multiple of both the
denominators it will be  The LCA of 8 and
12 and That Is 24 It Is the Smollett Common
Multiple of Both These Numbers
Now let's see the procedure of getting both the
denominators equal to
24 We want to write 5/8 + 7/1 as sum number
up to 24  Sum Numbers Up 24 We Want the
Denominators of Both the Rational Numbers Equal
to 24 To Make the Denominator of the First
Rational Number Equal to 24 We Have to
Multiply the Denominator 8 by 3 and to
Keep the Rational Numbers Equivalent We Also Have to
Multiply the  The numerator is by 3 and 5 and
3 is 15. The first rational number can be
written as 15 by
24. For the second rational number we have to
multiply the denominator by two to make it
24. We also multiply the numerator by two to keep
the  Value of the rational number
unchanged 7 ta 2 = 14 The second rational number can be
written as
14/2 ts it the first step is over we made both
the denominator same the second and the third
steps are simple in the second step we add
the  Numeration Over the Denominator We Can Write the
Sum as 15 + 14 / 24 That Equals
29/2 We Just Added the Numeration Over the Common
Denominator in the Third Step We Have to
Simplify It to Standard Form 29/2 is
Already in Its Standard Form  And Then Comes Our
Final Answer The Sum of Those Two Rational
Numbers Equals 29 Ba
[Music]